Speaker 2: Mypillow CEO and founder
Mike Lindell, known to us as Pillow,
the guy who wants to sue the machines.
Speaker 1: We're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines.
Speaker 2: He spoke outside the Trump
rally in Ohio. Remember, his phone was recently
seized by the FBI at a Hardee's drive thru pillow
is potentially in very serious trouble legally.
We looked at the search warrant last week.
He spoke for almost 90 straight minutes
outside the Trump rally. And his brain
is mush. His brain is much. Check this out.
Speaker 1: I was in Georgia on November I mean, on
January 4th of 2021. And I was down there at that
big rally for the two senator runoffs. Right. And
they said all of a sudden, I started praying and
I go, God, please let them take both of these
senators. And you're going, okay, Mike, you get
it? No. Okay. The reason I say that I'm a marketer
and I'm going to if I was if I was working for
that evil, I would say give them back one of
these senators so they shut up about the election.
Okay. Now, they don't that maybe not you guys,
for most of the people in this country would have
said, oh, my God, you guys, we said that we got
we'll get them back in 2022.
Speaker 2: Any idea what
he's talking about, anybody?
Speaker 1: Well, I got news for
you. There wouldn't have been a 2022. They would
have been over if they would have been smart and
just give one better. But instead, you all knew
exactly where you were when they stole them. All
right, everyone's got, you know, what are
we going to do? Maybe they're wonderful
at true crime. You know, people that were
on the fringe are all going, you know,
100 million people in this country with my wife.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So not making a lot of sense
is Mike Pillow. And then last clip
here. As you might remember, again,
it was the FBI who executed a search warrant on
pillow, took his phone and so on and so forth.
Now he says he will be suing the FBI for
the violation of basically the entire
Bill of Rights. Listen to this.
Speaker 1: Okay. My lawyers and
I got together in the last couple of days.
Speaker 2: We got together over a Hardee's.
I couldn't tell you what they have over
a Hardee's, you know, chicken sandwich.
Speaker 1: I guess on Tuesday we're showing
the United States government and the FBI. Yeah.
We're sure we're begging for similar reasons
for condemning the Writers Guild for.
Speaker 2: The more amendments he mentions,
the more the crowd cheers the lawsuit.
Really amazing. I mean, truly, truly incredible
stuff. And this guy is in serious trouble. He
really is. And, you know, we like to joke
about pillow. And he was recently all over
our Facebook page leaving all sorts of comments,
arguing with many of you as some of you notice.
It's all fun and games until the FBI takes your
phone and Mike Pillow could be in serious trouble.
And remember, he would be much better off if he
had just stuck to selling pillows and slippers
and straitjackets or whatever he sells. He would
be better off. Trump would have been better off
if he never got involved in any of this stuff. And
now it's going to be years of problems for them.
But there it is, a complete house of horrors
sideshow outside and before the Trump rally.
But the scariest moment, probably the Trump
rally itself, those incredibly cult like
moments with his fans holding up one finger. And
if you know what that was about, let me know.
We're still trying to figure it out. Crazy,
crazy times in the United States of America.